the increasing pace of digital
transformation has made cyber security
more critical than ever
new reports of high-profile cyber
security breaches emerge almost daily
with even the biggest companies falling
victim to these attacks
with trillions of dollars at stake as
well as the security and privacy of
billions of people and their data
highly skilled cyber security
professionals are needed to defend
critical infrastructure against the
ever-increasing sophistication of cyber
attacks
to design and implement a strong
security program that protects both
enterprises and individuals
organizations need security architects
who can balance the best practices of
information security management and
incident response at scale
that is why udacity has built the
security architect nanodegree program
with leading industry partners to teach
you the technical and business skills
required to be a successful cyber
security architect and leader in the
industry
this program's world-class curriculum
will not only teach you how to build
complex cybersecurity solutions
but also how to deploy solutions at
scale for large enterprises with
countless
endpoints you will gain the skill sets
required to serve as a subject matter
expert in all areas of security
and you will be able to integrate
network security
endpoint security
cloud security
and threat response into a larger
overall defense strategy
instead of covering a small attack
surface you'll learn how to work with
security components at the system level
to design secure systems that thwart
malware hacker intrusions and denial of
service attacks across an entire
organization
as cyber threats evolve and become ever
more complex the skills taught in
udacity's security architect nanodegree
program will help you stay in demand
enroll today
[Music]